[Music]
good morning everybody it's seven
o'clock here in the uk very welcome to
spend your breakfast with us here at sky
news will the army be helping us fill up
our tanks they've been put on standby
and with many petrol stations still
experiencing problems there are calls to
let key workers jump the queue we'll
speak to the deputy chair of the british
medical association who says there's a
real risk that nhs staff can't do their
jobs
also who's in line for a platinum
jubilee medal from the queen we'll be
discussing all of that with the royal
biographer angela levin at 20 past eight
and
[Applause]
the name's taylor rocky taylor as daniel
craig prepares for his last bond we'll
speak to a man who knows the pain
involved in making a bond movie it's
tuesday the 28th of september army at
the ready the government put soldiers on
standby after petrol pumps run dry amid
calls for them to let key workers queue
jump
if we had a client that fell over for
example how am i meant to get there like
that when i've got hardly any petrol in
my tank and i've got all these lines
that i have to sit in it's ridiculous
the government hopes that supplies will
return to normal in a few days but
motorists are still joining long queues
at petrol stations
i'm live at court where a man is due to
appear this morning charged with the
murder of primary school teacher sabina
nessa
r b performer r kelly found guilty here
in new york after victims battled for
decades for justice
here at the labour party conference in
brighton it's a big day for kierstarma
but he faces a showdown with the left of
his party
condemnation from the u.s as north korea
carries out another suspected ballistic
missile test
i'm live in la palma as larva oozes
towards the sea fears of a toxic
reaction
shaken and stirred after 18 months
daniel craig's latest and last bond
premieres here at the royal albert hall
and i've been lucky enough to meet him
my surgeon came to set
and watched me work for two days because
he couldn't understand why he kept on
breaking things and he went oh i get it
now i mean it's just bond doesn't walk
into a room it comes through the window
[Music]
premiere this evening how exciting very
good morning the army has been put on
standby to help deal with the fuel
crisis which has caused petrol stations
to run dry across the country following
panic buying but the government says
soldiers will only step in if necessary
this amid cause for key workers to be
allowed to queue jump to fill up their
vehicles shingi maruiki reports
this is now a problem so widespread it
may need military intervention
[Music]
with queues building pumps emptying and
tensions rising at four courts across
the country the government says military
tanker drivers are now on standby ready
to be deployed if needed
this strain on the supply chain is now
so severe in some places drivers from
the army are receiving special training
on how to help the petrol industry as
that ministers say is precautionary for
now
at the station in southampton they sold
four days of fuel in less than 24 hours
as people piled towards the pumps i've
literally got 10 miles
i stay 10 miles because it states 10
miles but it's on the last bar
the impact of the fuel crisis is already
being felt in people's lives care
manager kirsty guy spent yesterday
covering calls for two other members of
staff i've got carers that are refusing
to go to work because they're like i'm
not wasting the last in my petrol i need
it for school runs i need it for
emergency reasons
um even finding a petrol station that's
got fuel at the moment it's just it's
horrendous it's really really bad i'm
rushed off my feet
the numbers on her dashboard a glaring
reminder she might not make it to work
tomorrow leaving vulnerable patients in
danger
if we had a client that fell over for
example how am i meant to get there like
that when i've got hardly any petrol in
my tank and i've got all these lines
that i have to sit in it's ridiculous so
that person will be on the floor for how
long if they don't have any if they
don't have an alarm which most of our
clients do but if they don't have an
alarm or if they don't have a neighbor
that checks in or a family member how
long are they going to be there for
concerns like those mean the chief
executive of one of britain's largest
groups of doctors is calling for
immediate action this seems to be a
spiraling situation so it needs to be
tackled immediately and the government
needs to take responsibility what i have
seen so far from the government is a
denial that there is a problem
environment secretary george eustis
speaking on the great debate on sky news
and sky showcase blame the shortages on
panic buying
why can't the government now make a
decision and do something constructive
instead of blaming
everybody else not actually looking at
themselves because it is their failing
we should not be put in this situation i
should not have this conversation with
you right now but i am because you
failed simple you simply failed i don't
think it's helpful to over complicate
things and what we should be focused on
is making sure that we get the supplies
back in to these garages and actually
get the demand levels down to normal
as cues stretched into the night once
again one thing is certain these are
dramatic scenes which may need drastic
solutions and the army will be ready to
roll shingi marurike sky news
sadia in manchester for us this morning
hello to satya good morning what's it
looking like there this morning
good morning well it's a bit intimate
and sometimes there are queues here and
then sometimes the four court does sort
of empty out but it has been like that
as you've seen across the country but
you've just heard there the government
is putting so much effort into trying to
resolve this issue the defense the
transports the business secretaries all
working together so on the one hand
you've got the army uh perhaps um
ready to deploy if if needed but on the
other hand drivers who already can
drive fuel lorries are being told that
if their license expires so they need to
do training once in a while if their
license is due to expire between monday
today
and the 31st of december that will then
get extended
until uh next january so that's january
20 20 um
2023 so quite a long extension there for
those uh lorry drivers um i'll just step
out of the shot so you can see some of
the cues and of course this comes as uh
unions are urging for
key workers to be prioritized uh doctors
and nurses amongst them the bma saying
that they don't rely on fuel just to get
to work but also to do their work to
receive medical supplies and also to get
to
patients who need urgent care and you
know it's also ordinary drivers
yesterday i met a woman taking her
daughter to university and um
she had to do it on the train she had to
take it uh take her daughter by train
with all of the things that they were
they were carrying to move into
universities you can imagine how long
that is and this woman was in tears i
also met a boy who missed his stop and
then he was looking at 150 pound taxi
fare because of course don't forget taxi
drivers also rely on this to do their
jobs and you know fuel prices are going
up as well so not just key workers
ordinary ordinary drivers also hoping
and uh watching to make sure that this
issue is resolved as soon as possible
we're just looking at the chap and
filling up his um jerry can as we're
chatting to you um one of the issues
that the government was uh pointing to
about the challenges that people are
basically just um taking more fuel than
they than they need and there he is
tucking it behind
the vehicle as he's uh as he's filling
up this morning have you seen much of
that
um some of it yes uh driving here as
well we've seen some petrol stations
with queues and
people trying to plan ahead i think if
if you're being told that fuel is going
to return to norway the next few days
many people can't wait that long lots of
people are are hoping
to you know go away for the weekend next
weekend they're thinking about how they
will travel many of us have spent a long
time already indoors and perhaps people
are keen to make sure that they're not
constrained
by fuel prices like this one okay thank
you thanks a lot
very thing that the government is asking
us not to do deputy chair of the british
medical association dr david wrigley is
joining us hello to dr wrigley thanks
for joining us on the program this
morning you uh well there is a
suggestion that emergency workers should
be able to jump the queue at petrol
stations what do you think
well this morning to be many health and
social care workers will be nervously
looking at the dials on their dashboard
to see if they've got enough fuel just
to
undertake their daily work and you know
a lot of work goes on in the community
looking after patients who are
desperately unwell and we're just asking
that we are allowed to get on with our
job and you know if we haven't got
enough fuel then clearly that will
affect patients and we're calling for
the government to take action today
to let us know how we can get on with
our work and look after our patients
um government um telling people not to
panic by just seeing um a chat there in
manchester
as we were chatting to our correspondent
uh in the field
filling up jerry cans that's not going
to help is that
well i think obviously it's an important
message to tell people not to panic but
it's human nature when we know that
there's cues and people want to buy a
petrol but we're talking today about
health and social care workers wanting
to get on and do their job and now we
can't be waiting in queues for two or
three hours for petrol or diesel when we
have patients to see so you know we do
need a system in place today we have no
information at all about how we get
around this problem how we deal with it
if our if our fuel is running very low
we have patients to see so we do we need
urgent action today from the government
now they designate a local fuel station
for priority critical workers that's one
solution but we've heard nothing at all
and i hope the government act today on
this
what would you constitute as a critical
worker
well you know health and social care is
teamwork so it's it's not just about
doctors it's nurses occupational
therapists physios we're all out there
in the community day in day out looking
after
critically ill patients those are end of
life
palliative care patients and we're
trying to keep them well relieve their
symptoms try and keep them out of
hospital you know and that's what we're
there every day doing quietly and
silently for the nhs and we want to
carry on doing that but we're just
concerned that we're not going to be
able to because our you know we'll run
out of fuel during the day what about
those who are you know cab drivers
though or food suppliers as well
couldn't they also i mean everybody can
make a case for them being a critical
worker i suppose
i agree i mean that there are many many
people who need fuel so to
keep life going keep the economy running
and
the government needs to look at this
urgently and make out uh a plan about
how we deal with this because we can't
continue out this day today we're told
it's going to be over in a day or two
but you know we can't risk that we have
to ensure that we've got enough fuel to
do our day-to-day work and in particular
you know from my perspective to for
healthcare to look after my patients
and what about um we believe that the
army is on standby we're being told but
not actually being called in at this
stage um
what's your message to the government on
that one
well if that's needed then we need to do
that immediate urgently because if that
allows us to uh continue to do the work
we do for those critical workers
to look after people to ensure we've got
enough food to make sure there's
healthcare in place then yes let's do
that because we can't dither and wait
and just see and hope that this settles
down we have to act today
and what is the situation where you are
um doctor up there in canforth
well we're seeing petrol stations that
are empty there's long queues uh
people waiting for fuel and that's what
worries me i'll be i'm in my surgery now
i'm starting soon i'll do some home
visits later and you know like many
others if if i need fuel then i can't be
waiting two or three hours because i've
got patients who are very unwell to see
and many many other colleagues who work
in the community will feel the same way
and as i said with we've had no
information at all no no
no no no nothing has been told to us by
the senior managers by the politicians
to the health and social care workers
and that's just not right we want to get
on with our job uh but we can't do that
if we haven't got
the transport to do it and as i say so
much work goes on in the community to
help our patients that we need action
immediately
a couple of decades ago now i remember
there being a fuel crisis um when tony
blair was in power i'm sure you do too
um what was the situation then um were
you given an option to be able to queue
jump
yeah something that was about 21 years
ago wasn't it i was a trainee gp then
and i remember it well and we had we had
them uh passed to get through into fuel
stations in order to do what i've just
said to get on with our what the
important work of looking after patients
and that that could work again and but
as i say we've heard nothing so
we just we're just hearing words but no
action and that needs to change
okay today is what you're saying you
don't have time to to wait any longer
people my colleagues will be
on very low fuel worried about getting
to patients and that they need to focus
on their patients and not be focusing on
the fuel dial
okay doctor um good luck um today i hope
you managed to get the fuel if you need
it we appreciate you taking the time
still to come on the program 45 past
eight this morning speaking to the
shadow home secretary nick thomas simons
at the labour party conference in
brighton
london marathon takes place this weekend
we'll look ahead to it with event
director hugh brasher
[Music]
and then at half past nine two
paralympic medalists will be with me to
talk about a new initiative to give two
million million visually impaired people
better access to sport
before all that though um a story that
we can update you on about a man who is
expected in court today charged with the
murder of the london primary school
teacher sabina nessa
aisha sayed is at willston crown court
for us i should tell us more good
morning
yeah coachee santamarcia is the man in
question he's expected here later this
morning after he was charged with sabine
nessa's murder last night by police now
he was initially arrested on sunday
morning during the early hours around
3am in eastbourne east sussex that's
where he's from and at the same time the
police also seized a vehicle and this
micro which was parked around half a
mile away from where the arrest took
place now a vigil was held in memory of
sabina on friday evening her
family members attended as well as
friends and lots and lots of members of
the public to remember her she was only
28 years old when she was murdered she
was a year one teacher at rushie green
primary school in catford now the murder
took place on the 17th of september
sabine had been on her way to meet a
friend at the depot that's a pub
not too far away from where she lived
she it was a journey that should have
taken just over five minutes but police
believe that she was attacked in
cateford park in kidsbrook just minutes
away from her home so
hopefully today today we'll start seeing
some more answers into what happened
that day
okay for now thank you
the r b singer r kelly faces up to 20
years in prison after being found guilty
in a sex abuse trial in new york the
singer's lawyers say he's disappointed
by u.s correspondent martha kelner
reports
he was one of the biggest r b music
artists of a generation now our kelly is
convicted of running a criminal
enterprise of sexually abusing boys
girls and women for two decades
his defense team dismayed despite weeks
of damning and disturbing testimony what
did he say what did mr kelly say to you
mr kanek
he is disappointed as i am
you didn't get to see what we saw in
terms of the discovery
you didn't get to see all the
inconsistencies
we
said in our summation that the
government cherry picked their version
that they thought would support
the continuation of the narrative
they did traveling the world and winning
three grammy awards but a jury decided
this was also a front for grooming
beating and degrading young women for
his own sexual gratification
the attorney who represented many metoo
survivors says mr kelly is the worst
abuser of them all
i have been practicing law for 47 years
during this time i have pursued many
sexual predators who have committed
crimes against women and children
of all the predators that i have pursued
however
mr kelly is the worst
kelly's relationship with another music
star aaliyah was at the center of this
case the prosecutions say our kelly
bribed an official to enable him to
marry her when she was just 15 believing
she was pregnant and he could force her
into an abortion
mr kelly now faces decades in prison the
music industry also stands accused of
turning a blind eye to allegations
against him for far too long martha
kellner sky news new
york levels of illegal drugs found in
the river running through the
glastonbury festival site are at such a
high level they risk damaging wildlife
the researchers discovered that during
the festival levels of ecstasy and
cocaine in the water was so high they
even threatened a rare population of
eels downstream of the site
more than 17 000 migrants have crossed
the english channel since the start of
2021 more than double the total for all
of 2020. the figures based on home
office data come despite the government
saying it would make such crossings
unviable
uefa's dropping legal action against the
three remaining clubs who were still
committed to the so-called european
super league it's after real madrid
barcelona and juventus argued in court
that the attempt to punish them for
setting up a breakaway league was
against european competition law
fines imposed against the nine other
clubs involved will also be dropped
lava is continuing to head towards the
sea in la palma leading to fears of more
toxic reactions well our correspondent
becky cottrell joining us now live from
la palma this morning my goodness it's
always so dramatic isn't it in the early
hours the images of what's happening
behind you good morning becky
yes the volcano really is bright and
burning this morning there's a larger
spray of lava further up near the top of
the volcano and then a bit further down
this giant fountain of lava it looks
like it's a few hundred feet high now
this volcano has been unpredictable
since it started erupting yesterday the
tremors completely disappeared for a
couple of hours and we thought that it
all might be over and then they started
again we were speaking to a
volcanologist he said that's quite usual
with these kind of eruptions but they
can't predict how long they will go on
for he thought it would be several weeks
now the next thing that everyone is
waiting for is if and when that lava
reaches the sea it's a very steep slope
from the top of the volcano down to the
coast and when we last heard the lava
was around 800 meters away now when if
that lava does hit the sea it will
release toxic water vapors containing
hydrochloric acid it's dangerous to
breathe in and it irritates your eyes
and your skin and that is why local
authorities have warned people in the
surrounding neighborhoods near to the
coast to stay inside now yesterday they
said they thought it was imminent that
the lava would reach the sea it hasn't
yet so we are still waiting for that how
quickly that will happen will depend on
how quickly the lava is moving
okay thanks becky thanks a lot pretty
dramatic pictures continuing there from
la palma lots of people uh having to
relocate but thankfully no casualties um
to speak of at this stage now madame
tussaud has gathered waxes of the six
stars of james bond to mark the return
of the iconic spy in the film no time to
die
and what a lineup it is all the wax
bonds will be on display to the public
from the 30th of september each one is
dressed in a tailored suit of course the
lineup is fronted by craig with sean
connery
timothy dalton of course and the rest of
the bonds from down the years simon
templar there well not simon templer
roger moore but simon templar uh to
those of us of a certain age who is your
favorite bond why don't you tweet me and
let me know mine i have to say not
really roger mo probably
i like piers brosnan but i think it has
to be the original bond doesn't it
doesn't it i think it does
maybe not that one now the labour leader
sir kia steps back on policy rather than
party infighting live now to brighton
and tamara standing by for us
today a few more challenges for him
today the leader good morning tomorrow
kay well the party is grappling with the
fallout of a resignation yesterday you
never want a resignation but
particularly not overshadowing your big
moment at the party conference now kia
stammer yesterday lost andy mcdonald
what you need to know about him is he
was the last survivor of jeremy corbyn's
era he was in the shadow cabinet but
very much aligned with jeremy corbyn
there he is he was hailed as a hero at
this left wing rally last night he said
that the party was divided and he was
annoyed with them for not supporting a
15 pounds an hour minimum wage which
sounds like it's going to be a key
demand of the left of the party now
people around kirstar are saying that
they're not shedding any tears over his
departure the party has changed and they
think it is a good day when people from
the jeremy corbyn era want to leave and
yet those who left the party such as
louise elman who left over anti-semitism
have returned but sakir stama who a lot
of mps i must be honest are hoping that
he will start talking about what
everyone else is talking about which is
petrol shortages what we do about it is
now facing more headlines about
infighting and there may be a bit of a
moment at the conference later today
when there is actually a vote on the
idea of a 15 pound minimum wage so we'll
see if that gets through okay tomorrow
thank you
quick look at the weather for you know
and the rest of the suite will be chilly
with brisk winds and blustery showers
although there will be some brighter
spells in between
still to come on the programme for you
the army could be mobilized if fuel
shortages continue over the coming days
we speak to the fair fuel campaign who
say the government has been ignoring the
looming hgv driver crisis not to come
[Music]
it is pretty bad
people lose their properties lose their
their ownings and it is dramatic
but it happens on
one part of the island and in the middle
of the island there is a huge
mountain and
volcano so luckily our lighthouse is
exactly on the other side
protected by these mountains and
therefore we don't even
see detonations or lava or smoke so
people who live on the side of the lava
are really in trouble to save their
homes and properties
the lava cannot go to the north
but it is
quite a bizarre situation on one side
the lava is floating with thousand
degrees and our main
guy loses his uh plantage there and on
the other side we are in the paradise uh
at the infinity pool of the lighthouse
but that's how the world is today
and actually
most of the tourism on the island is
still
still active and working and also the
smoke and the ashes don't get to the
northern side
because of the wind the
don't like clouds with ashes so
when the wind turns and that happened
yesterday
the flights would not go anymore so that
is the main problem for an island
the tourists can get there
and still ships are going from tenerife
and the other canarian islands
and they increase the number of ships
but
when the airports are closed
then the stream of tourism is cut
we don't understand that every lake or a
pond is a habitat in itself
which houses frogs snakes crabs turtles
birds so many different life forms
human beings directly depend on
underground water source so a lake or a
pond is necessary to replenish these
groundwater resources
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and again you're watching the breakfast
show here on sky news the british
medical association has warned that
people who are unwell will suffer during
the current petrol crisis the army has
been put on standby to help deal with
the fuel crisis which has caused petrol
stations to run dry right across the
country following panic buying but the
government says soldiers will only step
in if necessary speaking to me earlier
the bma's deputy chair dr david wrigley
called for key workers to be given
priority in filling up their vehicles
like many others if i need fuel then i
can't be waiting two or three hours
because i've got patients who are very
unwell to see and many many other
colleagues who work in the community
will feel the same way and as i said
we've we've had no information at all no
no
no no no nothing has been told to us by
the senior managers by the politicians
to the health and social care workers
and that's just not right we want to get
on with our job uh but we can't do that
if we haven't got
the transport to do it and as i say so
much work goes on in the community to
help our patients that we need action
immediately we do we need urgent action
today from the government now they
designate a local fuel station for
priority critical workers that's one
solution but we've heard nothing at all
and i hope the government act today on
this last night saw the first episode of
the new sky news and sky showcase series
the great debate with trevor phillips
among the guests was the environment
secretary who was taken to task by an
nhs worker that said she thought the
government had failed on the issue
i mean where's the leadership i mean
where why you know
you all you've stated so far is it's a
media it's that it's it's the customers
taking too much at the end of the day
you know where is your leadership and
where are you stating where do we stand
as key workers are you going to give us
priority yes or no i mean why is he left
to the individual for court to decide
again why can't the government now make
a decision and do something constructive
instead of blaming left everybody else
not actually looking at themselves
because it is their feeling we should
not be put in this situation i should
not have this conversation with you
right now but i am because you failed
simple you simply failed
failed the answer is to as i said get
the no
but she's saying come on she heard that
she's saying make a decision
tell us that you're in favor or not
don't go don't go missing well what i'm
saying is uh i don't think it's helpful
to over complicate things and what we
should be focused on is making sure that
we get the supplies back in to these
garages and actually get the demand
levels down to normal levels it's
already gone from a 50 increase down to
yesterday it was about 20 above normal
levels there's signs that this is
calming down now and that people are
getting back to normal buying habits as
soon as they do uh this situation will
be resolved
i don't know about howard cox of the
fairfuel campaign hello to you mr cox
thanks for joining us on the programme
um this morning um
do you think
demand is going to be eased in coming
days and if so um
why is it so bad now
good morning case it's privileged to be
on your show um that key work or that
that nhs work was so right the
government are fully to blame for this
and and we've been warning them for the
last 15 years we're backed by the road
haulage association
and logistics uk and what they we've
been warning the government this
calamity this doomsday scenario or the
hgv driver shortage for 15 years and
they've had buried their head in the
center thinking everything would be rosy
and then we get grant shacks coming on
tv and radio saying don't panic is
everything's gonna be okay that's the
worst thing to do is to tell people not
to panic and you cannot blame drivers
you cannot blame them whatsoever for
actually trying to actually chase
the elusive uh uh filling up of their
diesel petrol vehicles and it will
continue to get worse i'm still hearing
most of the garages are empty at the
moment especially where i am in rural
areas because they're the last to be
filled up what we're seeing is that most
of the oil companies are actually
concentrating things like motorway
service stations and the reason being
they're more profitable they can charge
higher prices and it's terrible that the
profiteering is actually a result of
what of the government's incompetence
so you think the situation will get
worse before it gets better yes i do for
the next two or three days i still think
we're going to miss the situation where
one people are still going to be
panicking because they've got to get to
work and particularly the key workers
and and i'm also adding small businesses
and the white van man going to actually
do a job to actually you know put food
on his table he's actually making
decisions now that where he has to turn
down jobs because he can't get there
these are the sort of things that are
happening and
really what we're looking at is classic
government you know looking at sticking
plastic solutions rather than actually a
long-term plan to actually encourage
people to get into this profession
um the government uh are very critical
of people uh panic buying what would you
say in response to that yes and that's
that's absolutely right i'm not
condoning panic buying it uh the problem
is in particular i got one a garage
ringing me yesterday and they sent me an
email of a photo of a of a receipt
petrol seat for 90 pence uh someone
actually just filled up the tank and
that's just stupid it's really pathetic
but what we could do is actually
encourage people and and it's happening
already in most garages of rationing um
you don't need to fill your tank full up
you're not going to drive 400 miles
today or tomorrow in in most cases just
fill it halfway or even a third full
just to get you through for the next two
or three days that's my recommendation
to people let's relax and we can help
the situation but the government are the
ones behind it so i'm so angry with them
and so are our 1.7 million supporters
so it is a much longer issue longer term
issue as you were saying and it relates
to hgv drivers we are being told that um
some hdv drivers 5000 or thereabouts
will be allowed to come in from the
continent but only for a three month
fixed term period do you think that can
fix the problem
no not at all it won't touch the sides
whatsoever it's a it's a nice initiative
but what's the point of you just made
the point three months they've been
asked to come in why would they want to
do that
the only reason they do it is if they're
being paid double the money or something
like that but how are they going to
integrate into systems into businesses
and who's going to manage them all that
sort of thing
it's a good idea but the numbers are too
little and it's too late it won't happen
the only thing we can do at the moment
to get back to some sort of a normality
is to get the uh 100 200 military
drivers to actually start delivering to
four cops because all of the tankers
refineries are full up with diesel and
petrol ready to go we just need some
drivers bums on seats
why do you think the government has not
um
put that into action until now
i haven't got a clue it's i mean i
watched uh george used to listen to
george's i've listened to grant chats
and again they they're this well they're
pontificating it's it's unbelievable
they this is an anti-car government they
don't think about long-term strategy we
need a long-term road user strategy and
above all in the hgv driver's shortage
we must make this an attractive
proposition my daughter is 29 she drives
a 40-ton truck she takes all the right
boxes she's young and she's female and
she loves the job but that particular
image isn't being portrayed all we're
seeing is that they're being demonized
and most people when they get stuck
behind a lorry they shouted it they
forget that what's in the back of that
lorry probably is putting food on their
table or medicines
in their medicine chest
so what i'm seeing is the government
just haven't got a clue regard to road
user transport and and it's getting
worse by the day
why do you think mr cox that people
don't want to stay in in the profession
is it just because of the image or is it
as we've been hearing increasingly the
facilities are not there for drivers on
the road
all of the above okay i mean it is
terrible i mean for example you know
when a driver has to stay overnight he
has to sleep in the back of the cab you
know it's cold facilities are bad etc
like that and going to the loo and
watching himself and having a shower
these cities they're often closed
they're often charged 50 pounds just to
park to have that privilege et cetera et
cetera i mean that's been a long time
and also wages are bad this these
headlines are saying they're earning 50
to 80 000 pounds it's a myth it's not
happening at all but this is an
essential service and it should be
declared as an essential service along
with nhs workers
good to talk to you hopefully we'll see
some breaking the log jam soon um thanks
for joining us this morning appreciate
it
thank you
let's bring in uh grant keenan should we
who has created a driving academy to
help keep his fleet of trucks on the
road hello to you mr keenan tell me
about um your academy
good morning k um yeah we've basically
had no choice what we've had to do is
take um people from outside their
industry
pay their wage train them for three
months and then pay for their huv test
and then employ them as drivers because
we've had no choice just because of the
the shortage
and how's that working out for you um so
it's working well so far in terms of
there's um i mean there's been thousands
of applicants to the scheme and that's
the easy bit the hard bit is actually
keeping the trucks moving at the moment
and one of the things that really does
concern me is that i'm all for um
increasing drivers paying conditions
absolutely they're key workers but a lot
of the haulage businesses in any company
that's running wheels they can't make a
margin if they're paying drivers 50 or
60 000 pounds a year so the worry for me
is that over the next few months
we'll start to see businesses going
under
so what's the answer to that because um
given that we're just hearing from our
previous contributors saying it is an
essential service and they should
drivers should be paid more and have
better facilities um who's going to pay
for that
well i think the answer is is really
quite simple is the the three-month
extension to the relaxation of visas is
how our cox quietly said won't touch the
sides it needs to be at least two years
to let people come in and fill that void
just now it's maybe not a long-term
solution but we're certainly not going
to solve the problem in three months and
you know who's gonna want to come from
europe um to come over for literally
eight weeks for the time the paperwork's
done
to be told on christmas eve goodbye
thank you we no longer wish your
services anymore this problem is going
to be with us for at least 12 months
maybe 18.
um
i get that but there aren't enough
drivers on the continent are they so
you know
poland's struggling and germany is
struggling other european countries as
well so do you feel that that is the
silver bullet that you know if we do
allow them to come drive us from europe
for a year or more um that they will
come to the uk
i think i think you're quite right okay
however we are we have limited um our
pool we're fishing in a much smaller
pool so it's by the very nature it's not
as competitive um i think it's got to be
a cocktail of solutions and the
relaxation of visas is one of them
speeding up tests is another the thing
that's really hurting the industry is
how long it takes to get a provisional
license it's taking up to three months
which that'll be christmas gone by that
time already so we have a real big
problem with
so do you feel that the situation's
going to get worse before it gets better
yes i'm afraid so um i think it's going
to get worse right up until the new year
i think we need some drastic action now
um i think you know scrapping the three
months and making it at least two years
um is going to entice people back but
nobody is going to come over here and
solve our problem for less than three
months work
why should people want to be a lorry
driver an hgv driver what's the
appeal um it's a great job um yeah the
the conditions could be better but
you're in charge of your vehicle you're
traveling you're seeing a bit of the
countryside depending on what kind of
job like ours it's quite physically
active as well so you're getting a real
um mixture of um things that make a lot
of people happy granted it's not for
everyone but um a lot of people really
love hcv driving
and is it welcoming to women
unfortunately no okay it's not um i
think the standard of facilities and
services throughout the country needs
radical improvement you know i mean
i mean you can't really expect even men
you know to to put up with the
circumstances of which uh they're
expected never mind women you know there
needs to be a real mindset change and we
would welcome women into the industry um
we've had women drivers in the past and
they're absolutely superb
good to talk to you thank you very much
indeed mr kinion for joining us thanks a
lot thanks gary thank you mr kinion who
set up his own academy in order to train
drivers for his business but he's very
um skeptical about what's going to
happen between now and christmas uh his
view is that it will get worse the
situation between now and christmas and
drivers on the continent will not be
coming here just for three months is
that something that the government is
going to have to look at again mr keenan
suggesting that two years as a minimum
for the for drivers to be enticed back
to the uk
meantime north korea has fired a
suspected short-range ballistic missile
into the sea in its latest weapons test
in the region why well the japanese
prime minister has put his country on
heightened alert as a result
early this morning north korea has
launched what could possibly be a
ballistic missile
in response to this situation i have
asked my government to collect
information make the utmost efforts in
analyzing the launch swiftly provide
relevant information to the japanese
people check safety for aircraft and
ships and be fully prepared for any
contingencies
on our south east asia correspondent
siobhan robbins joining us now live from
bangkok um hello to siobhan good
afternoon where you are any coincidence
that the north korean representative
speaking at the un
okay you know all too well that
everything with north korea is very well
timed and i think the timing of that
speech
really is important let's quickly go
over the facts we know so this test
happened at 6 40 local time
this morning as you heard from the
japanese prime minister there the
possibility this was a short-range
ballistic
missile test if it was that means it
breaks various un bands uh we've heard
already widespread condemnation around
the region but also from the us which
has said that it's destabilizing that
although the test doesn't pose an
immediate threat to itself or its allies
that it continues to be steadfast
ironclad it says in its defense of south
korea and japan so let's look at that
timing you were alluding to so there are
two things that are important playing in
here it's just a few days since north
korea dangled the prospect of renewed
peace talks with south korea and the
possibility it would consider a formal
end to the north korean to the korean
war which finished in 1953.
also as you say this test happened at
the same time that north korea's
ambassador to the un was giving a speech
at the general assembly and in that
speech it warned the u.s that if it
wanted peace in the region that it
needed to stop having these joint
military exercises which it routinely
hates the us carrying out with south
korea it also said it needs to remove
its strategic weapons
from the peninsula so timing is
everything with north korea this was
about getting a high impact headline at
a key moment on an international stage
bringing itself back into the spotlight
very clear messaging to the us and it's
important to remember that after those
talks broke down with donald trump
in 2019 there hasn't been really
positive communication between the u.s
and north korea since then we're
actually told that they have ignored uh
requests
by the biden administration to reopen
those lines of communication so a very
clear message from north korea this
morning okay siobhan thank you thanks a
lot
just want to bring these uh images to
you unfortunate news about uh an animal
up in the northwest unable to find its
way home it's a white stag he's been
shot and killed by police marksman after
it was seen running through the steep
streets of um a merseyside town there he
is
found in an industrial state on bootle
on mosey side a merseyside police and a
vet who unsuccessfully tried to control
it making the animal more distressed as
time went on they say they were unable
to find an organization available to
help secure the deer so we're forced to
put it down for the sake of public
safety apparently the rspca said don't
do that it will eventually find its way
home um
the police shot it
fears afghanistan's economy could
collapse under taliban rule we'll speak
with a humanitarian leader live from
kabul next
[Music]
[Applause]
i witnessed how the catalan fight for
independence split families it was from
this chamber the carlos putimon declared
independence in october
i come here because i want to show other
people what happened
i'm michelle clifford and i'm sky's
europe correspondent
it's not the aim of the smugglers to
actually get people to uk shores but
simply into british waters
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
there are real concerns here now about
whether the health system will be able
to cope
we have to choose which patient is able
to survive
president macron has spoken in defense
of freedom of expression saying france
won't give up its caricatures and
drawings
made by people who dare to challenge
afternoon mr barnier how are you
i have no time for any politics
[Music]
anger about wider social and economic
problems in this nation
we are on the verge of fascism and we
have a country
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm sky's chief
correspondent
you either live and recover
or you die
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello again everybody the fuel crisis
continuing for another day today we'll
be updating you on what's happening at
the pumps very shortly but first let's
take you to um afghanistan now where
there are fears the country's economy is
spiraling out of control under taliban
rule its feared banking system within
the country is on the brink of collapse
with the threat of humanitarian crisis
growing by the day joining us now from
kabul is jan egeland secretary general
of the norwegian refugee council hello
to mr eglin thank you for joining us on
the programme just how dire is the
situation in afghanistan
it is much worse than i expected when i
came here i sat down with
a lot of men and women women separately
to ask them how are they fearing these
are the displaced people these are the
people who fled from conflict from
drought from from from all of the
problems over recent months in
afghanistan and they tell me
we have no income anymore there is no
no one having an income in our network
we do not have food we do not have
shelter that will shield us from the
winter which is coming in weeks
we need humanitarian aid
so i want to transmit that message now
to to the donor countries to the nato
countries that left this place uh
eight weeks ago
it's the same civilians they left behind
that are now in a free fall we need now
to scale up humanitarian relief
dramatically and we also need to have a
system for getting financial transfers
banking system to work so that we can
succeed
two issues there um let's let's take
them separately should we what
humanitarian aid is needed and then uh
longer term how does uh the west start
to shore up the banking system
well the the humanitarian need that is
needed is really life-saving one at the
moment of course our messages to the to
the taliban is
we cannot work
if not our female and male staff are
equally able to work so in seven out of
the 14 provinces where my organization
is we have resume work with male and
female staff we're working on the
remaining
seven we cannot do education if we
cannot do
boys and girls at the same time we're
making progress here but now it's
winterization programming as we call it
that is that is needed so we're
procuring massive
quantities of
blankets and and clothing and heating
and and and tents and shelter for the
people who have nothing we will also
have to do that for food
and we're working with the un and other
humanitarian partners here so that it is
not going through the authorities
totally independent from them directly
to the people
the west should have seen this coming
shouldn't they
well yeah what they should have seen
coming is
cutting
development funding that kept
hundreds of thousands of teachers and
nurses and doctors and watch engineers
and public employees afloat overnight
would lead to a collapse and the wider
uh society so what i'm surprised really
is
there
where are the trust funds where u.n
agencies could
pay public salaries
that the world bank is holding money for
why wasn't that prepared really it it's
it it's the same
40 million civilians that that were
helped before that now we're left behind
we didn't go for the door we are here
but we're
too alone really as humanitarians
[Music]
you